THE SUBURB OF IRPIN IS FREE OF
RUSSIAN TROOPS BUT THE CITY TOO
DANGEROUS FOR CIVILIANS TO
RETURN.
MY NEXT GUEST MADE IT OUT OF
IRPIN JUST BEFORE RUSSIA AIR
STROOINS DESTROYED AN APARTMENT
BUILDING.
REPORTING FROM A WAR ZONE AISLE
TAKING CARRIAGE OF HIS INFANT
SON.
♪♪
♪ OOH, OOH, YESTERDAY WAS SUCH
AN EASY GAME TO PLAY ♪
NOW I NEED A PLACE TO HIDE
AWAY ♪
OH, OH BELIEVE IN YESTERDAY ♪♪
HMM-HMM, HMM-HMM, HMM-HMM-HMM ♪♪
>> AND ALEX JOINING ME NOW.
ALEX, FIRST OF ALL, THAT WAS
BEAUTIFUL, WHAT YOU DID THERE
FOR YOUR SON.
YOUR SON WAS BORN JUST TWO WEEKS
BEFORE THE WAR STARTED.
TELL US ABOUT HOW LIFE IS GOING
FOR YOU RIGHT NOW?
WHY HAS IT BEEN IMPORTANT FOR
YOU TO DOCUMENT YOUR DAILY LIFE
FOR THE WORLD TO SEE?
>> WELL, YESTERDAY IS THE RIGHT
SONG FOR THIS SITUATION.
I'VE BEEN SINGING IT TO MY FIRST
SON WHO'S 25 YEARS OLD NOW, AND
I SING IT TO THIS KID AS WELL,
AND WHILE I'M SINGING IT NOW, I
REALLY, YOU KNOW, REFLECT ON IT,
AND I WAS REALLY SHOCKED AND I
STARTED CRYING THAT SOME OF THE
WORDS REALLY ARE ABOUT THIS
SITUATION.
ON BEHALF OF THE MAN I USED TO
BE.
I'M HALF THE MAN I USED TO BE.
THERE'S A SHADOW HANGING OVER
ME.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT THE SITUATION
NOW.
WE, THE, LIFE CHANGED COMPLETELY
WITHIN THIS TOWN.
COMPLETELY.
>> YEAH.
AND IT MAKES YOU THINK ABOUT,
YOU'RE A PARENT.
THINK ABOUT YOUR OWN KIDS AND
HOW YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO HANDLE
THINGS GOING THROUGH WHAT YOU'RE
GOING THROUGH ALEX.
AND YOU KNOW, WE JUST REPORTED
ABOUT THESE HORRIFIC IMAGES
COMING OUT OF BUCHA WHERE
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
SAYS PEOPLE INCLUDING PEOPLE
TORTURED AND KILLED.
CITIES LYING IN RUINS.
IT'S AWFUL.
WHAT IS IT LIKE TO SEE THESE
REPORTS DAY AFTER DAY KNOWING
YOU'RE ONE OF THE LUCKY ONES?
>> WELL, YEAH.
THESE ARE THE, THIS IS WHERE THE
WAR ACTUALLY STARTED FROM THE
NORTH.
AND YOU KNOW, MY HEART IS
TEARING INTO PIECES, BUT THIS
IS -- WE WERE LUCKY TO ESCAPE IN
THE FIRST DAYS, BUT I, I
ACTUALLY EVACUATED ONE FAMILY,
BUT THREE DAYS LATER IT WAS
ALREADY IMPOSSIBLE TO EVACUATE,
AND THE PEOPLE WHO I KNOW, MY
NEIGHBORS, TRIED TO ESCAPE IN
CARAVANS OF CARS AND THEY WERE
KILLED.
CIVILIANS WITH KIDS, WITH SIGNS
"CHILDREN" ON THE CARS WERE
KILLED.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S EYEWITNESSES.
I AM NOW, I FEEL LIKE THIS IS MY
MISSION TO COLLECT THOSE
EVIDENCES, TESTIMONIES AND I
HELP THEM TO TALK TO
INTERNATIONAL LAWYERS AND TO
GIVE THEIR TESTIMONIES, AND, YOU
KNOW, I'M PRESENT AT THOSE
TALKS, AND I -- I REALLY
SOMETIMES JUST, I CAN'T STOP NOT
CRYING.
YOU KNOW?
>> OF COURSE.
AND WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO SAY TO,
YOU KNOW, THE RUSSIANS WHO ARE
CLAIMING THAT, YOU KNOW, THE
IMAGES THAT WE'RE SEEING, THE
ATROCITIES ARE STAGED AND FAKE
AND SO ON?
I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY, WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING IS LUDICROUS, BUT FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE WHAT IS YOUR
RESPONSE TO WHEN YOU HEAR THAT
SORT OF THING?
>> NOTHING.
I WILL TELL THEM, NOTHING.
I TRIED FOR THE FIRST WEEK TO
TALK TO MY RELATIVES, TO, THE
ONES WHO I KNOW IN RUSSIA, AND
THEY ARE COMPLETELY SILENT.
THEY ARE COMPLETELY BRAINWASHED,
AND I -- I DON'T WANT TO SPEND
MY NERVES AND ENERGY ON THAT.
I'M GROG TO COLLECT THE
EVIDENCES.
I'M GOING TO HELP THE VICTIMS
AND THE EYEWITNESSES, AND I'M
GOING TO DO EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
THAT, THAT THE INTERNATIONAL
TRIALS WILL HAPPEN, AND THOSE
WHO DID IT WILL PAY.
THIS IS WHAT I'M GOING TO DO,
BUT I WILL NOT TALK TO THEM.
>> AND YOU SHARED ANOTHER VIDEO
OF HOW YOUR SON HAS GOTTEN SO
USED TO HEARING THE AIR SIRENING
GOING OFF THAT HE BARELY REACTS
ANYMORE.
WE WANT TO SHOW VIEWERS THAT AND
TALK ABOUT IT AFTER WE PLAY IT.
[ SIREN ]
>> ALEX WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU'RE
GOING TO TELL YOUR SON ABOUT ALL
OF THIS IN THE FUTURE?
WHEN, YOU KNOW, WHEN HE CAN, I
GUESS POSSIBLY UNDERSTAND WHAT
WAS GOING ON DURING THIS
TERRIBLE, AWFUL TIME?
>> I WILL TELL HIM THAT HE
STARTED HIS LIFE IN THE TIME, IN
THE HISTORIC TIME WHEN THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY GOT TOGETHER
AGAINST THIS EVIL, AGAINST THIS
DEVIL, BECAUSE THIS IS, THIS IS
NOT EVEN A WAR.
IT'S A MASSACRE.
IT'S A -- GENOCIDE.
THAT THEY CAME TO ERASE OUR
NATION, AND EVERYONE IS
FIGHTING.
EVERYONE IS FIGHTING IN THIS
COUNTRY FOR OUR COUNTRY, FOUR
OUR LAND AND FOR HUMAN VALUES,
AND FOR, FOR FREEDOM, AND I'M
SURE THAT WHAT IS HAPPENING NOW
WILL CHANGE THE ENTIRE HISTORY
OF THE COUNTRY, OF EUROPE, AND
OF THE WORLD.
>> ALEX DAYRABEKOV, OUR HEARTS
GO OUT TO YOU AND YOUR SON, AND
KE